لقد كنا نضيع وقتنا
في المواجهة والحرب الساخنة في نهاية الأسبوع
للحرب الباردة ، لم ينجح الأمر بالنسبة لنا على الأقل ،
ونعتقد أن
هذا سيعزز موقفهم في
حل هذه المشكلة
في الوقت الحالي بصفتنا الإمارات العربية المتحدة.  النظر
إلى فرصة يمكن أن تخرج من هذا
والتي تساعد كلاً من
الكثيرين على الاعتقاد بأنك وقعت على عدد من
الموس ،
وكما نقول في نافذة اللغة الإنجليزية ، لا
تظهر الكثير من الأشياء
داخل ما هي
الحجة المضادة لذلك
ما تم توقيعه حتى الآن وليس  على الإطلاق
شيء واحد تعرفه في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، نحن لا نضيع
وقتنا في المزيد من الاستخدام ،
المزيد من المستخدمين مجرد نوع
من المستندات لضبط وتيرة
ما ستفعله ولكننا نعلم ما
تريد القيام به.
العمل ونعرف كيف
يمكننا الحصول على الأعمال التجارية
، يتعلق الأمر بتبني التكنولوجيا ، إنه
يتعلق بالخدمات اللوجستية
، يتعلق الأمر بالاتصال ، يتعلق الأمر
بقدرة كل من التجارة والقيام بالأعمال التجارية ،
نحتاج إلى شيء منهم في
التكنولوجيا يحتاجون إلى شيء منا
يحتاجون إلى علامتنا  وآخرون يحتاجون إلى موقعنا
الذي يحتاجون إليه لمعرفة كيفية قيامنا بأعمالنا في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة
لأن الطريقة التي نؤدي بها أعمالنا
مختلفة تمامًا ، فقد ظلوا في عزلة لفترة
طويلة ، وأنا أفهم أن اليوبيل كان
مهمًا جدًا لدرجة أنهم لم يريدوا ذلك
للتوقيع على الاتفاقية
ما لم يكن هذا جزءًا منها ، فما
الاستراتيجية الكامنة وراءها هل تسمح
للشركات الإسرائيلية بالدخول إلى المنطقة الحرة
أه تجميع
الأجزاء وتصنيع المنتجات أه في
المستقبل من
الواضح أن كل ما سبق بشكل عام هو
مجتمع أعمال نشط للغاية مع  عند الوصول إلى
الأسواق ، ننظر إلى الهند وباكستان
وبنغلاديش وسريلانكا والمناطق المحيطة بها ، حيث
تحصل على ما يقرب من 2 مليار
شخص ،
وهذا هو السوق الذي يرغبون في
الوصول إليه والجمال هو أن
الوصول إلى هذا السوق أمر سهل للغاية
هذه
الاتفاقية الجديدة مع إسرائيل مع جبهة موحدة
بين دول الخليج
النامية وإسرائيل
تؤدي في الواقع إلى السلام مع إيران
لأنها كانت شريكًا تجاريًا كبيرًا
قبل العقوبات المفروضة على دبي أعتقد أن
أي تطوير  لن يكون لإسرائيل تأثير إيجابي على المنطقة في مجال الأعمال التجارية ولكن ضد
إسرائيل ،
حيث سيخلق الناس المزيد من الأعمال التجارية التي
سيستفيد منها الجميع
ومن يدري أنها قد تكون خطوة إيجابية
بالنسبة لهم
ربما لإيجاد طريقة للخروج من
مشكلة العقوبات التي لديهم  هل
تجعل المنطقة بسبب
العلاقات التجارية التي تطورها الإمارات العربية المتحدة وإسرائيل
أكثر أمانًا أو أقل أمانًا ، ستكون المنطقة
أكثر أمانًا
بدلاً من الاختلاف مع الناس ، لماذا
لا نتفق على الأقل ، انظر إلى ما
نتفق عليه  حول
لماذا لا ننظر إلى الأمر بشكل مختلف ، فهذا
سيؤثر على
جعل حياة الناس أفضل والذين يمكن أن
يختلفوا مع ذلك